so now that we have a better
understanding of what this google play
games library does for us let's start
using it so i'm going to go to our
downloads folder and I'm going to open
up our as of yet unused Play game
services folder and in here there's a
bundle and a framework and we're going
to add both of these into our Xcode
project just click and drag them in
again if you are storing this in a
centralized folder that maybe many of
your applications were using you might
not want to copy items and keep it as a
reference in my case I do just so this
is a nice little standalone app so I'm
going to click finish and there they are
so I'm going to drag my framework into
my frameworks folder and and there you
go important step is done there are a
few other steps we need to do before we
start using this library the first is
kind of an obscure 1 i'm going to go
into my info.plist file and I'm going to
add a new entry right click and do a dro
you can also do this by going to like
editor add item and we're going to call
this gpg application ID and this is the
11 or 12 digit number that is associated
with our application and there's two
ways you can get this the first is if we
were to just look at our client ID it's
basically the same number here so we can
just copy over this first numeric
portion of our client ID you can also
get this from the Google Play Developer
console if we were going to play google
com / app / publish and guess my number
this number right here that is also the
application ID so you can get it from
either place either way I'm just going
to copy it go back to my info.plist file
and paste it in there we go and then the
next thing we're going to do is go into
this
ACH file this is our precompiled header
and i'm going to add an import statement
here i'm going to add Play game services
/ Play game services H I don't know why
it doesn't like to in M it but it
doesn't and this is sort of a nice way
of importing this basically into any
file that I'm going to use just to avoid
having to import it all over the place
because at some point you'll probably
forget I suppose this is optional if you
want to skip the step and just import it
manually and any file that's going to
use Play game services feel free to do
that as well I just find this is easier
for me next let's go back to our intro
view controller and let's go to our
finished with off handler and this is
basically where we left off we had our
auth object and we haven't done a whole
lot else with it well now let's let's do
that now right above are finished with
off method I'm going to create a new
method called sign in to Google Play
games and this is essentially a method
that we will call to set up the google
play games library and generally
speaking we access this through a shared
singleton instance kind of the same way
we did with GPP sign-in the name of our
singleton class is gpg manager gpg here
standing for google play games we're
going to access the shared instance and
then we're going to set up our of'
information with this library by calling
sign in now there are two arguments that
we pass in here the first is a GPP
sign-in object so again we access this
through the singleton method shared
instance and the next we pass in a
reauthorized Sandler or block this is
basically a handler that our gpg manager
needs to call if auth fails for some
reason typically this might happen if
say your user plays your game for over
an hour and their access token has
expired you might have noticed that they
all have an expiration time of 3600
seconds a less common situation might be
that a user has gone into their account
settings and revoked their permissions
for your game but your game it still
attempts to for instance submit a score
to a leaderboard so in both those
situations the manager needs to know
what to do and in general the correct
thing to do is just try signing the user
and again and so we'll do that by adding
in this code so if requires keychain
wipe which in general means we've gotten
a signal that we kind of want to clear
out all the old cache data we can call
from our shared instance sign out and
this completely signs the user out from
the google play games manager which
means that it drops all cached
information it does a few other cleanup
tasks to ensure that the user really is
signed out on this device but then in
either situation will probably want to
try signing the user and again and to do
that we will call GPP sign-in shared
instance authenticate which is the same
method that gets called when the user
clicks the sign-in button and again
everything goes well it will pass the
results to the gpp sign ins delegate
method which is right below are finished
with auth error handler so again going
back to our most common situation of the
users been playing for an hour and their
token is no longer valid and then they
attempt to unlock an achievement our gpg
manager will get back a response saying
hey this token is no longer valid it
will go to its reauthorize handler in
this situation requires keychain white
will be false and it'll say ok I guess
I'll just authenticate the user again
this will happen silently in the
background it's a silent authentication
that should succeed and we're able to
continue like normal don't worry if this
code doesn't entirely make sense to you
this tends to be kind of boilerplate
code that people just kind of copy and
paste from our documentation but it's
worth kind of knowing what's going on
and then all that's left to do is call
it and so in our finished with auth
error handler I'm just going to say you
know if there's no error
let's call sign in to google play games
and that's it and so let's run this and
see what happens Hey look at that that
welcome back Todd Kerpelman message that
is the google play games library
actually doing a fair amount of work
behind the scenes it's taken my oath
token it's used that to get my player
profile my name my avatar URL and its
use that to display a little
notification message at the top of the
screen and all that gets performed
automatically as soon as i call sign in
on that shared singleton instance and
that's pretty cool i didn't even need to
know my oath information at all and in
fact if you'll notice this oh f to
authentication object doesn't actually
get passed into sign into google play
games it gets all the auth information
needs from this GPP sign-in object which
is kind of cool too so that's pretty
good we're starting to look more like a
real application next up let's add a
sign out button and maybe perform a few
cleanup steps will do that in the next
lesson
haha